Hello, thank you for participating in the 2021 Ellent Wearing
Tip A Cell Train 20 Minutes
Mars, which you are currently participating in, is the
Basic & Mention House course.
We will
also introduce
the considerations and
solutions for using
the triple
code off suspicion count.
I'll take the time to watch the video.
If you have any questions, I'll give you an answer after watching the
erotic video you left as text in the qna window.
I am Lee Bo-hyun, who is in charge
of the customer workshop and in this system of the system.
Nice to meet you.
I'm going to talk for about an hour
, focusing on the keep that can prevent or keep your bb performance constant.
Trouble shooting
I'll break it down into catalyst parts like this.
Now, first of all
, I'll tell you about the
basic principle of
kg.  will be
detected.
So the picture you are seeing now
shows the basic structure of the word in general
Messe s.
uh
basic sample intro and then
quadruple mass tam dao from there
riser then divorce
detector parents are basically the same so
I'll tell you with this part first
uh sample a ionized uh ions a
ms an ally  When entering, the
on-scan mode generally selects a
model according to the people we are analyzing
, and according to
that, the detector at the back
detects the abuse of the 3 party agent.
Member We are talking about today  Let's try
that q has some structure is the
single quart structure we saw earlier,
and for the moon, the
aphite now has a
five-part grace
structure as shown in the figure below.
The orca pole part that is in charge of the divorce transition that sends the growth to the negative scalpel is composed of a total of 5 parts
: the optics, then the quadruple,
then the
detector, and
100 that have been subjected to great vacuum before
.
In
the case of a single code of what is a little different, the quad
is dependent on one. In
the case of sms, it
is solved by code.
Yes, the part called Jeonseri is included. This
time, it is not actually solved by cut,
but
the part where the ion is framed
.
If you want a ruffle
, it
is
driven by a scan or a needle, causing a collision with the divorces in the difficult cell, so that the
number of votes is
less
.
All currently existing tandem mass ukyo
q
quadro beautiful quadruple are all the same, but they
are tangled up in this structure.
Yes, there is a material that can be analyzed, but there is a material that can be analyzed using an
argon pass or a helium pass
.
There is one structure
in it.
I can tell you that this part is broken in the Cory charter, and the
mass messe component is very
important in this part.
So, what was the big disadvantage in single code?
Once those reasons
passed the quadruple, it
could not be
undone. Also, the major disadvantage is
that if there was a substance called 9 1 2 pack, his
object b, unfortunately, if the
molecular weight is the same, in a single code,
this part of the second  I couldn't do it for 9 minutes,
so what people came up with was
2.
Then let's physically break
these two substances.  Iggy
, so you can know the propensity for such a substance, etc. You are born with such a simple idea. Let's talk about Gen Art.
Things like the picture you see now are
typical examples
.  Kessler physically collided
and dug 150 5.8 and back. There is
only Kim Tae-hee hairy.
Fan
information about
155 5.8 and back pop
is called 285.
foreign matter
It was unknown how to
do
these operations in a single code
.
So,
it is actually a different substance, but if the molecular
weight happened to go 1, it
could not be divided into 9. In mass ms
, using the effect of collision
Ernie gave the material more identity
display,
so we have the code in front so
that the collision effect, which was in charge of the foreplay and presentation in the middle of the two quads earlier, is in Korea,
so the
code in front
operates the scanner  As I
thought, this kind of work is a combination of
several mass mass editors, but
Smith is
. You can control all 7 of the war choi you are seeing now
with a
combination.
A
scanning Of course, what scan refers
to ms2 scan.
Well, it's called ppi mode, so
Lions go through Babfor 2 and
put people outside, and the
cigarette area
doesn't work, and it's in
such a state that it just transitions only this clothes.
.  Prototype from there
, what kind of aion is coming out, in
ms2, the prototype that works with
scan is scan, then frigg
flicker science can
4 pa tights or
Ryu
troll sba sket request scan that is mainly used in
this way scan makes brain servants support scan
Yes, the
scene mode is supported during the m
single iron monitor
2 and the thing rose, and
we finally use buy buy
to make mrm conditions
.  So, to put it simply, the fact
that there
are more than two pieces of information on this srm can be seen as a weekend
act.
Now, this time, I will briefly introduce the hardware of the lg rental sample code.
I entered as a bit of a latecomer than in the competition,
and the model that appeared in the early days
is not on this screen now,
so I started with
Hexa 1 0.
Yes, the
positive code started with a total of 4 at first
, then 5, then
uh
2 As the years went by
, the know-how on the peak table of the two degrees
gradually became narrower
, so a lot of effort and investment was made to improve the performance of bd.
So, currently, only female six 70b and
six six 9c models are being produced
.
So, at present,
only two models are being produced, the 670 and the Yuksaku model. In the
early days,
the etiquette was that the structure of the tech pack model was
a serial method, so the equipment was
slightly larger than that of other companies,
and the PB was very large.
There were a lot of people who said,
well, in the early days,
well, as I mentioned
earlier, the zoom in the qq
market will enter the market as a bit of a latecomer, and
now we are developing mainly the
performance of equipment, so we need to have good performance to sell a lot now
.
Since we are now developing mainly
,
yes, we started with the display method at first, but since Yuksa 70 and
Yuksa 902 came out, in the middle
of it, the effect of the posture of each
issue is released.
If it's good
, that cell sweetie street where a lot of people are concerned about in advance
There is
a lot of improvement on the left for,
among them, some matrix effect or something like this
,
it is a state technology that makes it possible to
analyze the people's party by making sure that these things are yesterday.
Since each
pin angle is hung on this patent
, well
, each company bends it a lot, so the
angle is all different.
As the space utilization increased a bit, yes,
the models that are coming out now
are a bit smaller than the early models,
and
for that, the bent model has
a lot of adaptation for the matrix effect, so
it has
contributed greatly to the improvement of Abombo.
So  Genius is being created by Choi Gong and 6-seok
aunts, and
then Yeosu also collects a
lot of examples depending on the field of operation
.
Agilent chat
cream sauce
that calculated , then substances that could not be analyzed in the above sources,
such as those with
low polarity or very
high level of open substances with almost no polarity,
because analysis is impossible between examples.
If the app for analyzing the source is the source,
then the sound
app is small and similar in relief, but
this time, the episode
is forcibly discharged with a highball tag by the corona nitro
for a
short period of time.
There is also a source that generates photoelectrons and now makes
2 1r.
Then, what is called multi-
monsters starts by collecting multi-source sources at one stop without stopping one esi and ap cal at this ip source
.  After that,
there
are a few more sources that are not mentioned here, but I will not introduce them because the
masters are not currently being produced, or because they are
very discontinued or discontinued
.
With the code that consists of yo,
the mass language, the nutrition
part, and the number in front of it, it becomes a
circle
, so you can lift it up and find it as a grass effect.
It is composed
of three parts, that is, the detector part that
can
properly detect the car,
that is, the detector
part that can properly detect the car.  It
is a company that has very little know-how since it has a new code with parts that do, so it is very important in the control part of
this 5 tx 5
minute circuit lottery uh, now it is raining.
The 6-seok slogan of the same style
came out, but as all 2 Zerg Audrey came out with the iPhone
4 technology for the first time,
the no-
fix part changed a little bit
.
It consists of a total of 3 areas in this way, so
it is being operated.
It is the part
where you can receive a direct movie with that sensitivity because it is the material that
is separated.
My rising 2nd team Ferrari is made of glass.
Well,
yes, if you use it for a certain period of time, this will also become a
bit contaminated. Yes, cleaning or
amen.  It is also a part that you need to do.
In my daughter's 15 minutes, I'll introduce it once again. In the
4th event, the catch furry type that will be provided now offers the
total catch
type.
Old Caterpillar drops.
Speaking of our 2nd daughter line expression, so if you
compare it with the single holistic skin pack below and compare it to the difference picture, the
upper part in the middle is
that transparent, something transparent,
and the one below it looks a little opaque.
So
Traditionally, the old capillary on the lower level is the Cadillac and the lower one is the
difference between the Rystig Cube Pella b.
Well, after the screen source was developed,
the
Tapillar d came out for the first time.
It
came out because it was said to be a cap flight optimized for linking switching. It is now a
new capilano. It is now the second
middle dog,
so most of the people who have been trained will
have it installed on the filler like this.
The difference between the two  There is no sensitivity or anything like this at
all.
Uh, if you are just simply fast-plating
switching
number of copies, you must use
Steve Kepler d in the article below.
The mode to
do is called Esprad Ting Switching, but when the tube color is less expressive, it
has -4000 on the front end, and
when I do the skin, plus 3500
honey is filtered, and the
total of 7500 to 8,000 envelopes come
and go.  It's a lot
of work. So,
if you use the old capillary, it will cause a little more
load and cause some malfunction
, so you
must use the fastball lighting switching mode
to analyze the method
.
You have to use the estp decay villa Lee.
I have a core below Boris q2 capillary
, and the material per capillary in the middle is a
spring.
There are 6 holes in it
. The hexa earn street
capillaries are mainly six 9 0 hex 9
Aion Firm 4, which is not
a pad that is basically equipped with technology
. It has one hole and 6 holes.
In just one hour,
the amount of ions that pass through a single hole and the amount that passes through
a camp with six holes
drilled through it
will be different. The 6th generation will be different
.  Since the amount that passes through one month
is more than the amount that has passed through six months,
yes
, please analyze it at this time. If you compare the case of that analysis, yes, there
is some time for the 10 Hexa or Eastpak fly below to appear.  It
comes quickly
Yes, that's
why it's a big difference.
We provide perla d for all three species.
So,
depending on the model
you're using right now, you know what cappy you're using.
I'm doing a regular
company. I don't know if
the method of clinging is in the back of the 6th Fila Lee,
but I
'll tell you
again in the next data 20 this time
.
Because each piece of equipment
that does continues to maintain the same performance,
Example 4 Lee Jun-seo and Kashi will be
very helpful in such cover. I
will introduce a little about that part.
now come to introduction  Lee is already called the
source sms l misos dvb
, so when you install this software, if you look in the softbox, it is the software that
comes bundled with
it.  All manuals are now digitized so
that they can be viewed on a shank pc that can be viewed in a web-based way.
If
you look at accounting,
ms under data broken manual
rib line is
being provided.
It's a little more comfortable,
so
I'll introduce this briefly
. When you click on the side of the comment and you
can enter, the screen changes like this
, and the truth part on the gold that I want to see is
now displayed in the
form of 5 clip pen buttons as content, but it appears in the form of a
browser like this  Types of things that
can be searched like that are also created like this.
This is how it works,
so if you click on the part related to the part corresponding to the high part,
you can enter the
.
If you click on side l and go in
,
detailed items will appear again,
and here I am.
How to fill it If you click and depas the thermomu part,
when you add a rough bump oil, uh, you will
need
to prepare something like
that.
Uh
Now that it's blocked with a nut, things
like this app, paper oil, and paper that
can be cut like this
are needed
.
It will
move like this, but this is the video now.
Video 2
Well
, progress like this. There is a vacant lot
.
I want to see it once
Then here's q p in this section,
so you can play from the high part where you click separately for each key point
like
this.
I'm providing it to me, who wrote it to make it into a statue with better quality
. If you look closely at the title,
I think it will be a little tempting when you
are very
mentrance.  As you know, when you add
moisture, this side is at
atmospheric pressure, so you will always
do a
lot to make it cheaper.
If you do it properly, you will be able to maintain it, but if
you
used a mouse blood that you use when examining a sample of one kind,
or in this case, you copy the mobile right next to the heo as if you don't have a
picture in the middle right now,
or if
it's on the right side of the top of the main
because it's dangerous  With this, 100
g of gold, yes,
you can see that
it is awake.
This lint-free place uses
such a tone that can solve the lens, so it
's like something like that. We
're now white 4 wasted passion points.
You can
make ipa and take it. Well,
you can wipe this part after
finishing the four thousand. Here's what teenagers should be careful about,
this part is very dry, meaning that
the drying heated to 300 degrees or more is
exposed.
I'm going to see
you.
If you keep it awake
, maybe that part is
positive when you analyze it - 4,000
volts When
I went mostly standing, the pros
3500 dot maintenance highball terry was
caught, and
the ions I analyzed by the volte
were a
regular force toward the bath  It
's a delicious
place because it's pulled from and goes into the mass toe, but if the
fold is inserted like that and coated with that salt,
no matter how high-ball tees
are normally
narrated yesterday,
the reason why the ions are attracted to the
mass will be turned off.
If this
goes below the standard,
at the end of the sword stem, it detects as much as it came in, so
you
must feel it as a decrease in sensitivity to feel the brand,
so that part is the part where the sample was first introduced,
and then  It's very rich and
it's a part that requires a lot of attention, so I
put it in the middle. For the name you use, if you
look here, you can think of a half-half mixture of water and half IP, and a
50% eye pillar compensation. It
's best to use 5
these days.
You can buy a lot of May Fisher sauce from
the side of the example.  If you
buy a part that is shedding, but if you buy our mass
, a job mesh will come in in that self-application letter
. In addition, sapper sandpaper 5
4 podak Oh, yes, just
like that
.  If you use these for a certain period of time, there
are parts that need to be replaced now, yes,
instead
of
ac-cleaning.
Sequentially, when the phases
move to the scalpel, yes 2 thin
drum 4 numbers are now the
part that serves as the denominator.
If you do it here,
well, they are clogged, or in this case,
you need to check the nebulizer side for consultation.
There are 4 things on the screen you
are seeing now
.  I don't have it.
Well, the most used
part is in the upper right corner, and then you
use a lot of entertainment blazes that start
with 70%, and the bottom one is apc ae nebulizer
students.
this
Of course, it is not compatible, and we
are providing a separate method for si 0 oa pci.
It's a level that can
shed 5% alcohol in the nebulizer
balm. It's in the upper left corner, but
you'll use
the rise
You ca
n't see it, so my battle is
, if you hit
the nebulizer, I'll supply you with what's on the screen you're seeing, especially c
.
It consists of three parts, such as the back and then the
body to which the body can be mounted,
followed by the magnifying glass
.
After
that, there was a time when I made a magnifying glass because it
was a body, and compared to now,
I
kept in touch a
lot.  When the
background of the
nebulizer rises in a straight line with level i and the blue state is also
installed and the led is installed at 90
degrees, the level id can now
be seen from the front.
Now, the center of the nebulizer
is  But you can see the state in that part. Just
hit it now, like a 1
pushin screen, the feeling on the left is
saying the state of the nebulizer is very clean
.
boy
Yes,
you can check something like
this
.  It is in a state where you can see the length,
so it is 5 so it is in the
shape of a comb
.
You have to
check the length of the field
once.  If it goes into or like this, the boom
model is tilted at an angle, so
yes
, it can affect the sound sensitivity. You
must check this periodically.
It
would be nice if you could crack it a little bit if the stuff that has been
done is bushy. Hey, that
100ml measuring cylinder that you dream of abolition will be in your laboratory. In addition, you
can make half a
cup of methanol or say nothing, or say something like ipa. The taste is
okay.
I use it, mix it half and half
, avoid the yom s saliva, and
finally put it on top of the measuring cylinder, then wrap the request with p
film.
You can see that these things can be removed
so uh
food and profit and loss
have not been removed properly
and it
is not a problem that looks like it has been corroded.
After replacing the blade, the
work that must be done
Yes, you have to block the length of the nebulizer needle
again. Is this
a bit difficult to pour at first
?
After practicing a few times, I will give you
* 054
characters Basically, when operating
Messe, it is okay to check yourself once to see if you are doing one thing
.  If you look at it once,
yes, since you are using vacuum equipment, the
approximate state is quite important. If
the opponent gets the white and steps,
yes, the state in which the ions are blown away from the platinum
state is the air step. Then it will be
directly affected by the director I analyze.
Hacking is very important because it can be.
Oh, this is what monitoring is. It
is usually
100 pyeong after the high-back Yeongwol-ro of the software status window
.
Tomorrow, the sieve pump outside of the air love pump
is probably mostly installed with drums that return to oil,
but that oil is also not used when a boat that has only arrived once
is not used when it is self-defeating.
Not only that, but the color also changes and the
amount decreases
, so it just happens
that there is a frequency when the test comes and
goes like this.
Is it about
2/3 full?
Then, rather, what
kind of bubbles or what kind of things
are created? The whole color should be clear and clear.
such a state  If it's in a
bad state, you can
contact us as soon as possible. Then, if you
do a third autotune or
something check tune
regularly, you can do
it every day in the case of check tm.
The end will be the ladies of the grandmothers.
Yes,
at the end
of the chat, I will literally give you the status of the device now. So, if the
mass livestock is gone or the
avengers give me, I found
this status.
Because the book does not make adjustments,
analyze the tune every day. Try it with your vision, and if
all the criteria come out in pass green and the
meaning of pass pass, is the state of the story normal
?
It was stated that the above adjustments are needed during the lifetime
. 4 When the 10th generation comes out
, you can do the bottle.
Then which one should you auto-tune
?
So, if you receive soft reading, yes
, now you have to hack your wife off. 9
After washing your wife, you can do it again
.
You need to do it periodically, about once. You
must know about o2 once a month.
Then, as for the source,
uh, as
I said before, after analyzing it, you can give
it 58 da ip
,
yes ta kappa.
Uh, should I spring about once a year?
Yes,
about 5. Uh, I'll ask the member teachers.
Of course,
I know enough that I can't do anything other than analysis work.
is like this
It won't get worse Yes
uh As I said before, the way to add 101 status is in the
upper right corner of the software act.
After that, there
is a state range that is representative of the enemy, and
maybe fans have probably told you that you
can always monitor whether the state of
ratification has
come out.
You do it as if you use a lot of high-purity n2o cases,
but there are probably many places where the enter pass is set separately so that it goes through the cylinder now
.
If the goal is lost, Enter Quest will not enter the solution sales
, so
yes 2 Platinum ticket is quite good
Eojung gave me a heavily armed one
Yes it's not good The
enter case doesn't go in so
after analyzing the scalpel it won't be possible to analyze
yes n
Platinum will only get better
A
lot of people make mistakes if the requirements are open.
Well, then, the rough pump is
usually less than one port, so it's compatible now.
If anyone goes over 3 on this one,
please contact me.
The
primary element
is responsible for the platinum state of the source couple or the optics part,
but the second role is involved in taking the turbo pump
source slightly, e.g.
So, if the
rough bumps don't get better,
the efficiency of the turbo one will drop, and the
turbo one will say yes
.
If ,
be sure to be very sensitive to the round of beak,
shot 4 beep, then the format is what kind of scalpel and
background, and you have to stably draw the audience's
strings.
Eh
, what kind of normal c is normally followed by
when 100% of the solvent water without buffer is heard.
If
you try to capture the screen once like this, later when
a problem occurs due to a mobile page,
yes, you
can know exactly what this mobile pig problem is talking about
.
There are various reasons for the amount of other things
. Among them, according to our service experience, most of them have
a lot per pyeong because of the problem with the dragon.
Surprisingly, the
solvent is always now.
After Yes, because microorganisms are
generated,
you need to manage more sensitively compared to Bill, and
then you
will need to
manage
more sensitively.
I'm going to say the last part, but I'll tell you about the frc king. I'm
interested in getting involved in a lot of power in the normal turn, and I
'm sensitive to encountering a lot now when using 4 devices.  There
are a lot of problems with poor sensitivity,
yes, because there will be more stress
, so the lowering of the sensitivity is like the Kubera word now, ju data
. You always have to basically check three things.
4 I mentioned earlier 4 Bella win
Yes Yes The blazer is a little
clogged or something, so the
amount of ghosts has
to go in.
If you can't detect the director's
[ __ ], it will affect the sensitivity.
Then, periodically
, I told you to chat and auto-tune.
It's because the device is weak and slightly different every day.
But over a year, well, after
the parameter from a year ago was
built now, the wind will wear out the truth,
right?
I
can accurately judge what the current state of the device is with the results of the current device
.
So, if Autotune is
normal now, then
the background I mentioned earlier comes out Yes, how
stable it is low,
then the device I am using now
.  It's a representative state,
so you can check these things to see if it's appropriate.
After
that, the second one is about Lee Yoon-seo's pension,
but this is now
element fashion
.
Matrices and children will
now be negatively applied to the mattress month,
but the
matrix base is warm
.
So, to make it less sensitive, it is
called fashion, and
this is a must
.
3 examples of what I analyzed by subtracting this There may be something like this that
has influenced and caused Lee Yoon-seo fashion
Well, in
this case, there is no way. Add
or use
HPC.  In order to give it to you, I'm going to try to do it directly on the abolition page after the wealth
, the sensitivity and
nutrition directly
.  The concentration of the previous shot is
buried somewhere, so it
is called carrier O if it continues to come out at a certain level in a
buried state.
Or you can get a lane transformer
to prevent something in advance.
Well, you can tell me again. Ah
well, now when carry over occurs,
some 3 directly affect yes reduction.
So the easiest way to know is
To
see if the sampler works in two modes, we first say
that the state in which the solvent continues to work is
called the daily pass, and the
state in which the body does not flow is called the i-pass
.
With a water sample, you can know which part has a
problem.
So,
you can chat with these two attachment procedures.
Then, if the htc is contaminated
or the column is
contaminated, it is usually
excluded  If you are looking for a 4x part element in the service experience,
try replacing the column first
. Now, if you know the procedure, go to the Pearl
Widukdae and repay the column and
clean it
.
Let's approach this, so at first, if the
background increases a lot and you want to find
out what this is coming out
of the column, take off the column and the
injector bypasses this
state and yes,
100% volume is not contained, the
buffer is not contained
I mix 50 points at the cost of
a5 and send the purchase directly. The background
is high before
.
run back to man pass
then run memphis again without connection of the column
now um each 50% solvent
spilled out now flank this time
blank is yes
bare blank
um 00 micro 0 micro
more for the injection arm then sdf  *
You looked around, so I wanted to try it once by pressing it, and then the blank samples are now sample melted credit 4,
and with that, I try to inject yes in blank, and
the two results are
yes,
clean, then I go to the next wash.
You can
judge that it's a misunderstanding. So if you
do this sequentially like
this, you can check
whether this is a problem with the column side or which
part of the system.
Because it is a part that can be done, the section will now
accept the service in this order if it is given to the West to change the service year
.
There are cases where the mass spectrum comes out exactly
as much as 44m 4g. I
don't know if you tested this.
I've only experienced it twice, but
unfortunately,
here's the job right now.
Solvent I don't know if you know it, but you
know that
acn is not
a solvent made synthetically in a factory, unlike
its other appearance.  Each
individual is the key to whether the end of the sesame seeds are refined and released on the market. It is
2% bigger after graduating from high school
.
Reaction dash now, or something
industrial base, these ingredients remain in the solvent
.
If so, it
is formed with such a polymer called p20 polyether 7 and ply
corey,
such as Kim.
It seems like you were chatting at least once yesterday.
So, as I said before
, when the normal frame was abnormal, with 6 clean people, the spectrum that
came out when only the fisherman's body part
was spilled.
If you capture it
, when this problem occurs Yes,
you can quickly find out where the problem is
.
Well, the
dance solution in the heart of the show may be contaminated,
so this
autotune solution is contaminated.  There
are several materials that are lying on the floor, but since I
have been in the main house for a
long time, I am used to it and it becomes
thicker or
if this happens,
yes
,
you will slightly deteriorate.
It doesn't come out anymore
during the auto tuning race with the costume of the gwiju. If
this is the case, the auto tuning Nulji material is not a variation,
but now it is contaminated somewhere on the ki side
, why is it that the contact
nation 4 berry comes out for a certain period of time, but it comes out so much?  If
you say that it comes out as 100% yes, the tuning
solution has a problem,
so
you can know like this.
A tree called use a on the page
he Ellen Curie h Raminga tree
7 Arm is a bit too much Do you use it a lot You
can
use a buffer Yes Yes You have to use a buffer The analysis that only comes out
What do you know
When using a substance Saco Liverpool
Be very prepared and use it
. After doing this, for a certain period of time, the
system in the 2 Gabe has the property of trying to bite something to eat
, so if you use 2t for a
certain period of time, the Lion called 202 forms the background of the cow through a certain period of
time.
Yes, so the Aion called 200
If there is an IU nearby that I analyze, it
will not be able to properly fountain because it is interfered with.
You need to wash your system
and there is also something called tfa. If you order a
go-go shark, you will see a
lot of 113 Ionia
. Yo If you use the two pa pfa
, be sure to use the system and
then wash it thoroughly with water and then prepare for the next person.
I'll tell you that, in my
mind, the Kelly
Brent Squirt King solution I mentioned earlier is
degenerated or the frame is a solution.
Stoning Solskjaer It's always 1
scan data
here
.
Since this is the
length of the sound, it is a path that you cannot think of on your own
, so the proportion of ingredients that come up a lot is held back
.
It can't be wrong because the directors are all wrong,
and if you do auto-tune work normally
, 1 8 and 3, if you sizzle between two drinks, you
will definitely see the part that forms the background, but this
is normal.
In that case, what we commonly refer to as the
contaminant road is only positive, and
there are few of
them on YouTube
.
So, when I always do this part, I do it on
my meeting monitor, and the
Eso screen has a lot of sources, so
if you judge whether or not it is contaminated, it is
good data for
So Auto Tuning 2 is
quite important  I did
Well, if you look at this now, if it is cut off, uh, if it becomes
contaminated, yes, in
this way, it is recognized that this person
is now 1 8 entities, 1 Paris, here, 1 Paris
, Idiot, but it is actually 118.
More material comes
up Then he randomly
grabs 1 arm for example Then it will
shift as much as hobby 3
That's why it's twisted and gone
It's a style
dek fruit scent, so
think of it as an existing fact that it will be
exhausted within a year.
When you buy it, there are people who just close the box once
and put all the herbal medicine machines in. If
that happens, if it becomes like baggage, you have
to throw it away in a hurry. Yes
, you have to throw it away and
buy a new one.
Keep it refrigerated
Like it's your own Young penning This is what
you're looking at now This is this check can report If
you finish it
Yes everyone, the results will come
out 2 of all objections
There are so
many things like now that
it needs to
be adjusted just like now
.
Looking at it, the after wham exp has
to be adjusted to 7 doors with 0.7 peak yield skills such as resolution
Heo Heo-yoon Lee In-mo, but actually yes,
it's all wrong.
Uh,
if you know how to see it again, the
state of swelling Yes yo With some data, you can do
our stalls
. Now and the two of you, if Fell Brent
doesn't introduce buying at all, if this
phenomenon appears, the buying axis is also
correct.
Then the red ocean  All of Yu
Hexagon Fortunately, it doesn't fit, the important thing is yes, the
cap comes up, it's the street
floor, it's alcohol, nothing comes up
.
If you do a lot of our services,
there are quite a
lot of cases like this.  This is the result. Let's come
out very
cleanly.
If you get on it, you
have to come first and throw it away. Go up to
4 and see if this side is clogged. The
problem is, while the
nebulizer is connected,
pull it out counterclockwise to the top of tool 9. It will come off
.
Autotune in fashion mode with a new dialogue After
choosing the recently successful quiup file,
tumppa, go to the suit
panel and right-click to bring up this
menu.
It's normal.
Yes, you can do that. Yes
, if we come, it will be 6 years from now
. If it gets dirty a
lot, the symptoms are very
strange.
Looking at the 2 arms here, it's a bit out of my mind. Compared to the
others, the others are
n't that good, but the
beneficial s aren't coming out at all
.
Crab Yes Contaminated for a
long time The middle part has
changed into a slightly brownish brown shape.
Yes You can
tell by looking at the color this way.
It's coming up
And, as I said earlier, between 1 8 and
lives 2
, the part that says to
take 0 magic is normal.  You can judge it by being an older brother or something like
this.
Then,
I recommend a lot of these, but when you
use Cuke Passer,
errors about it occur, and depending on that,
teachers say a lot of the following.
If
you look at the top left and right, there
is a request in the shape of a log book icon in green.
So, if you click on a song, the
screen will appear
.  You will take
a look at the neck from the point of view of Aaron's eye.
Well
, it would be nice to have a watch.
What I explained today is lost
.
call
it busty  In fact
, I am now working in the team that conducted the workshop, and in our
team,
if we can't do 5 now, we will
die.
I started the
2nd Lecture, Saju Island last year. Last year, the 2nd
Lecture, I have a wilderness where instructors give lectures online in real time and
ask questions.
The online course is the
same as the one above, but
this is a pile
of lectures provided by teachers by recording
lectures in advance, downloading the file and having
a
half day, so the above is a
little different.  In , if the
resident is to
give Sam something about education according to the curriculum in , this is called
elp s learning n performer
solution.
If
you do, you can see it as
a fuller service if you provide training according to the match, so if you want to get more diverse information,
you can visit and visit the training while watching Balance Chicken.
You can see the qr code you see now
or the link here and
access it and
download it.
Then, if I tell you more on the extension line,
the curriculum for scalpel
is ready to ship in a variety of ways, so
at any time  It's about it, but you can check it out on the
homepage.
Uh, this course isn't running normally right now,
but soon after this time
passes,
everything will be back to normal.
Until then, stay healthy and have a
long day today.
Thank you very much for
listening.  Recording a video of what my stock is,
protest Bo-young, and injured are already together.
Please say hello briefly.
Hello, I am Lee Bo-yeon, who is currently riding in the
rooms related to the base mat side of the team due to the consideration I received through the bell.
I'll give it to you.
Is Grass Kepler Lee a communication?
There is a question asking if there is a way to reuse it
in Kling.
Compared to the parts, the old
nature is correct for
this phone, but yes, a
crane is possible
.  It's me with a map of 100 sheets.
Oh, take
1g and beat it with a pillow map electrode for water, then
melt it completely in the top character of sushi.
It's going to be that way Then you'll have to do that kak trat
twice and both ends Table 10
1st Messe Pipette p-level You
have to come to the shoulders on both sides Why is that
Matt Helen you too Fish
glass Rize Because the length on top of our cap lin is prettier
2nd starter Fritz when washing
To prevent the curd from breaking,
I used a pipette tip.
Our captain Aju has a lot of this lenser effect
TV, so
you have to wake up on both sides and then turn it on
.  What I just want to say
is that silver is thin after the home bar color, and the
note looks like it just dissolved in water,
but in fact it is in the form of a very fine powder in water.
I have to cook for you. You have to cleanly give p5.
So
, after washing is finished, do 2 times of 5 times with this clean water
, shake it off
, install it
on the equipment, and pump it down.
The way to do it is probably really
old juniors
, even if you ask a few questions once
, it's not that difficult if you do it. It's
possible through a new example.
I heard that profit can also be detected.
I have a question called What is the advantage of using this part when it is common
?
As I said
, if everything is done,
the form of measuring molecular weight becomes chaff in the form of matte tea
light.
To put it in words,
for example, if it is said that the popular misunderstanding is 1080 as a mat in the force app
, the molecular weight outside this range is
yes you 8 Murphy Packing is ang
.
It's so
cool, it's so cool, it's possible for all these cool guys
to do crimes, so
to put it simply,
even if you get out of the moo trainer,
yes, it's almost a point when analyzing polymers to some extent.
this state  This is the reason why
s mats are used a lot when most of them have high smear analysis.
One of the
bottles is a 4-multiple discrimination crab
form,
so the visual is a huge training called
Bota rather than the mat range of the sad map.
6:00 If
you have
any questions about cuts, you can
leave them in the qna window.
Today's notice, knowledge-building Beige Gang
Mant Once video,
anytime until June 25th, contact our euv ts again.
You can see it
in the bottom menu of our Heocheol site, and now you can see the Ong
Mention Seminar in the Auditorium
. If you look around the Software Center in the Hajan menu, you can
also get information on software related to Elent chromatography or mass spectrometry, and if
you leave any questions,  Our
specialist is answering. Also, there is a questionnaire in the
lobby. If
you fill out this one
, it will be very popular when we inject travel agencies in the future
.
It started with the first episode, and a
total of 17 of these rooms, i
've or recorded, are being conducted in Korean, English, and
Thai.
Yes, I don't have any more questions, so I think I've answered all my questions. If you have no
other questions, I'll greet you today with this.
thank you